your money is losing value the bank of  england is projecting that inflation  will hit 7.25  by april this year that's after  inflation already hit its highest levels  in 30 years back in december 2021. to  give you some context before banks  started printing endless amounts of  money because of the pandemic the global  target inflation rate was around two  percent with the uk averaging 1.8  percent to stop this soaring inflation  the bank of england for the very first  time since 2004 are imposing  back-to-back interest rate hikes of 0.5  percent the people running our economy  haven't got a clue protect yourself from  inflation and buy bitcoin